[Music]  there was a trailer for the new thor  sequel  thor the dark world  and i got to tell you it looks like the  action's even bigger than in the  original thor movie but i got to tell  you folks i have the same complaint i  had with the first thor film i think you  can argue with me if you want i think  they cast the wrong guy  to play thor okay check out the trailer  tell me if you  agree some believe that before the  universe  there was nothing  they're wrong  there was darkness and it has survived  i gave you my word  that i would return for you  not only to a few known only to one  oh snap  [Music]  hammer time  curve punch  i'm sore [ __ ]  [Applause]  [Music]  anyone else  maybe it's fine  smasharoo  masha rooney i think smasha rooney  where did that come from  let me hear that again smasher rooney oh  i didn't come to rehearsal today i  didn't know that was ready to go master  rooney  rehearsal  [Applause]  [Music]